[Music]
how's another mejía greeting you with his
briefing for today, thursday
july 22 you will have to put your mask
back on as soon as you go to work
today this rule started at
midnight clark county is
working with the health district
to  prevent the spread of the virus and
decided to return to the mandatory use
of masks for employees in
order to mitigate contagion, this rule
will be in effect until August 17
and if you have not yet received
the coronavirus vaccine, we tell you that
this Saturday there will be  a
montgomery cloud endemic clinic in the link from 11 to
6 pm hundreds
of prizes will also be awarded including tickets for yesterday
and for entertainment events
starting today the
nevada unemployment department will be asking
all applicants to verify the identity
of unemployment benefits
this can be done through the
aid program and ming this program has
been installed  since May but now it is
mandatory for more details you can
enter our page at this
diagonal dot com in Spanish
on the other hand the city of our
vegas will offer a back to
school event this Saturday it will be from 9 in the
morning to one in the afternoon in  the
amphitheater in front the first 2500
students will get a free backpack they will
also know free school supplies
for students and teachers they
will also offer a vaccination clinic
now we go to the weather forecast
we did not see drizzles yesterday but there are
chances for today with a maximum
in the 100  degrees temperatures have
changed in recent weeks we have
a cloudy sky for a few days and
more yogis for this weekend
remember to drive carefully have a
nice day I'm Héctor Mejía and this
was your brief hopeful news in
Spanish
[Music]